bienvenido a la presentación de
conversión de velocidades déjame empezar
con este problema supongamos que alguien
no se digamos lalo le voy a poner aquí
la lo la lo está manejando a 28 28 pies
por minuto 28 pies por minuto y queremos
determinar cuántas pulgadas puede
recorrer en un segundo es decir queremos
ver 28 pies por minuto
a cuántas pulgadas a cuantas pulgadas
por segundo es igual pulgadas por
segundo muy bien entonces tenemos que
hacer una conversión de velocidades
déjame copiar esta otra vez aquí aquí a
la a la izquierda entonces empezamos con
28 pies pies por minuto y lo primero que
voy a hacer es cambiar esto a pulgadas
por minuto y ya sabemos que hay 12
pulgadas en un pie bueno si no lo sabías
ahora ya lo sabes entonces aquí déjame
multiplicar por 12 pulgadas 12 pulgadas
dividir dividir entre un pie vale esta
de aquí es la tasa de conversión vamos a
ver qué nos queda
nos queda 28 por 12 déjame hacer la
operación aquí 28 por 12 2 por 28 es 56
1 por 8 es 81 por 2 estos aquí queda 6 5
y 8 13 y llevamos una y aquí es 3
entonces nos queda 336 336 pulgadas por
minuto
pulgadas por minuto y aquí hice algo
interesante o sea básicamente lo que
hice fue cancelar estos pies con estos
pies como si fueran números es aquí
tenemos pies en el numerador aquí en el
denominador entonces podemos cancelar
los arriba estamos multiplicando aquí
dividimos vale así que simplemente nos
queda pulgadas por minuto también
pudimos haber escrito esto como 336 pies
por minuto
pies bueno pies que en cada minuto
por pulgadas
/ pie / pie vale y aquí ya se ve que se
cancelan y llegamos a esto pero bueno no
me quiero meter mucho en eso de cancelar
las unidades más bien ya llegamos a 336
pulgadas por minuto pero todavía no
hemos terminado ahora tenemos que pasar
esto a pulgadas por segundo entonces voy
a copiar aquí abajo las pulgadas por
minuto son 336 pulgadas pulgadas por
minuto por minuto y ahora queremos
deshacernos de estos minutos bueno
cuántos segundos hay en un minuto hay 60
segundos en un minuto así que déjame
déjame poner aquí un minuto un minuto y
aquí ponerle 60 y abajo segundos y aquí
puede ser un poco confuso verdad me
puedes preguntar cómo sabes que arribaba
minutos y abajo va a segundos pues ve
queremos que los minutos se cancelen con
los minutos como aquí están en el
denominador los ponemos en el numerador
y bueno naturalmente los segundos quedan
en el denominador vale nada más hay que
ponerle aquí abajo el 60 para que esto
sea un 1
no afecte no afecte con lo que empezamos
vale o bien otra forma de pensarlo es la
siguiente
sabemos que hay 60 segundos por minuto
pero el 60 va arriba o abajo bueno pues
ahora tenemos menos tiempo para recorrer
verdad ahora vamos a pasar a segundos
entonces ahora la velocidad debe de ser
menor y por eso tenemos que dividir
entre 60 bueno entonces después de
pensar eso podemos cancelar minutos con
minutos y nos queda 336 336 entre 60
entre 60 pulgadas pulgadas por segundo
por segundo esta fracción la podemos
simplificar un poco tanto el numerador
como el denominador son divisibles entre
6 336 entre 6 es 300 entre 6 o sea 50
más 36 entre 6 o sea 6 56 y abajo nos
queda 60 entre 6 que es 10 nos queda 56
entre 10 pulgadas por segundo pulgadas
por segundo
y 56 entre 10 es igual a 5.6 pulgadas
por segundo pulgadas pulgadas x
segundo muy bien entonces con esto
terminamos el problema vale 28 pies por
minuto es igual a 5.6 pulgadas por
segundo así que el halo recorre 5.6
pulgadas cada segundo muy bien vamos a
resolver otro problema para seguir
practicando ahora imaginemos que tenemos
que tenemos le voy a poner 91 y 91 pies
por segundo
91 pies por segundo y eso lo queremos
convertir lo queremos convertir a millas
por hora millas por hora
muy bien ahorita voy a utilizar un
procedimiento que es un poco más rápido
pero es exactamente lo que hicimos aquí
arriba sólo que abreviado lo que voy a
hacer es poner los 91 pies por segundo
acá pies por segundo y pues aquí de
golpe voy a convertir tanto los pies a
millas como los segundos a horas va
entonces para convertir de pies a millas
tenemos que recordar que en una milla
hay cinco mil doscientos ochenta pies
entonces abajo nos tienen que quedar
pies verdad para que se cancele con
estos pies del numerador y arriba nos
tiene que quedar millas millas
entonces como te decía en cada milla hay
cinco mil doscientos ochenta pies estos
números son son bueno eso es bueno
recordarlos vale entonces aquí tenemos
cinco mil doscientos ochenta pies esto
se encarga de los pies
ahora tenemos que convertir los segundos
están en el denominador los ponemos en
el numerador abajo debemos de poner las
horas verdad para que lleguemos a horas
y cuántas cuántas horas
ay bueno cuántos segundos hay en una
hora pues en cada minuto hay 60 segundos
y en una hora y 60 minutos y 60 x 60 y
3600 así que hay 3.600 3600 segundos en
cada hora en cada hora muy bien entonces
aquí ya queda todo convertido a lo que
queríamos porque los segundos se
cancelan con los segundos y simplemente
tenemos que hacer la multiplicación de
91 por 3 mil 691 por 3600 dividido entre
cinco mil doscientos ochenta y eso ya va
a estar en millas en millas por hora por
hora
muy bien a esta multiplicación y
división van a estar muy difíciles
hacerlas a mano así que déjame sacar la
calculadora no hay problema digo cuando
las cuentas son fáciles se pueden hacer
aquí al lado pero si son números muy
grandes mejor utilizamos la calma
entonces 91 por 3600 es igual a este
número t y ahora tenemos que dividir
entre 5.280 muy bien nos queda 62.0 45
45 45 vamos a redondear lo como 60 y
2.05 ok entonces esto de aquí es igual
es igual
es igual a 60 y 2.05 millas y millas x
ahora excelente y con esto terminamos el
problema espero que te hayan gustado
estos problemas nos vemos en siguientes
vídeos